Sup y'all my name's Nick Forest
I think being a brother in psi theta would be awesome
I would do whatever it takes to get into this frat
I'm expecting to make some lifelong friend
Whatever it takes
Gentlemen welcome to psi theta epsilon
one of the oldest most prestigious
Fraternities in America
the man you see standing beside you will become your best friend for life
If you trust me
ask any member here this program works
Make no mistake about it. This is not gonna be easy
Some people in this frat
they are gonna make it as hard as possible
And I know that if you stick together
and trust each other
that you will work through it.
I can't wait to call you guys my brothers
I'm working on a new film project.
It's a documentary about fraternity hazing.
People are dying.
This puke caught us on tape doing some illicit things
You realize this isn't going to change anything right?
What they don't seem to understand
that when they send us underground
it only makes us more and more rabid
We talk about Brotherhood
you have to work for it you've got a hunger for it
you've got a lunge, die and bleed for it
Welcome to hell
What does brotherhood means to you?
It's an unbreakable bond
that you have for a rest your life
Hi Mom!